hello and welcome to see you're playing
cop cop a shaft oh I don't know
complicated names um
just thinking I can do something else
Joe it's such a solid opening this
London system this is a very classical
way of countering it 95 is the old way
to play this position
nowadays they mostly try to play with
the quickie four
is that the position where they go
before I think it is right yeah okay I'm
here right normally castles and then
place a for later or here not sure maybe
it's more precise to just start with
castling because now I didn't even need
to play Queen to c7 which is normal like
you provoke f4 and only then you go for
the 97 regrouping should each voice very
strange I mean I'm ready for f6 Knight
f5 that is my plan I went to e7 for a
reason okay now I can also check f4
[Music]
also looks like very looks very okay
let's take it
no white can recapture and then my piece
is also hanging okay why would that work
you came back to see seven
I'm a piece of huh just a piece of him
for basically not much okay so this one
probably I'm threatening Bishop d8 and
you have to ship the eight to looks like
a strong threat
maybe there's something better even it
is it looks fine though I mean he is not
threatening all that much energy for I
have to ship t8 an even stronger the
stronger version
okay it's cheek and now this is probably
a reasonably easy way to play it if I
get to take on f3 my Bishop my knight on
f5 is single-handedly defending the
hooker working side and now let's get
this rolling
the knight is covering g7 and is
completely safe on that square cannot be
attacked with anything
let's get some a deck so ya know age six
is lightly rotating actually so Queen D
but queen d3 is stronger yeah White King
has absolutely no squares and I'm
threatening Bishop DEA drug C aid while
rook c8 first membership to a less good
home cannot really stop Roxy aid yeah I
was a very odd way of treating the
opening like here this is normal I am as
I mentioned nowadays Eva is considered
to be the critical move in this position
after which black ghost should be seven
and is probably okay okay he went
tonight 5:57
and now the very early F for normally
white castle's him and after Queen c7
players f4 then ninety seven so I think
the game was a slightly improved version
of that because him I didn't even need
to play Queen c7 which is not very
essential yeah now he went to Bishop f2
hmm not clear why ninety-four normal
move Bishop h4 is just a mistake I'm
sending him back and now it seems that F
takes e5 wasn't even the best I should
just take him okay Knight f5 is a strong
move coming up here definitely true like
for example here
I have this F Knight f5 like take take
and Knight f5 I guess you know yeah it
is nice and this isn't even clear I am
remarkable you should take him yeah I
thought that would be better for black
but maybe this is not true engine just
wants to snap everything off him okay
hmm
I'd still rather be black here with this
this big weakness now it's it's not
entirely clear okay it took age seven
and chick and F it takes D takes both
better yeah it's just that's not
sufficient compensation okay here Bishop
d8 was better it should be a winner
Queen b5 was inaccurate okay and it is
so plus plus three for black n yeah he
played them pretty inaccurate opening
even though it seems like my FTC five
also wasn't great yeah I did not really
judge this correcting that that white
can actually hear that this is actually
okay the thought I would be better here
but it's nothing clear okay guys thanks
for watching